[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en 1968 c'est la trudeaumanie pierre
elliott trudeau est jeune et la 49 ans
ministre de la justice du gouvernement
libéral de l'est personnes il incarne le
renouveau le changement il
décriminaliser l'avortement et
l'homosexualité
n'a pas sa place dans les chambres à
coucher de la nation
[Applaudissements]
le parti libéral e choisi pour succéder
à lester pearson son programme un canada
uni progressiste et une société juste
[Applaudissements]
aux élections fédérales de juin 68 il en
face de lui tant mise en place du
nouveau parti démocratique réal caouette
du parti créditiste et le conservateur
urbain distinctive
[Applaudissements]
tout est dans l'image la campagne
électorale se concentre sur la
personnalité de pierre trudeau jeunes un
moderne un bras excentrique les jeunes
filles sont folles de lui du jamais vu
en politique canadienne m dos m'a dit
d'abord ses intérêts débiteurs politique
voyez sa télévision
août à david bernard de roms faisait
alors ses débuts en journalisme à
radio-canada dans l'émission intitulée
aujourd'hui co animé par michèle
tisseyre et où il fut élu
en 1968 le monde est en ébullition aux
etats unis avec la guerre au vietnam le
mois de mai à paris
[Musique]
s'est éveillée à 67 les nationalistes
québécois aussi ils se font entendre
nous vous demandons de vous joindre
pierre trudeau les a en horreur il jure
de remettre le québec à sa place
[Musique]
il était contre tout nationalisme
freedom est arrivé dès dimanche de
reconnaître les canadiens français
méritent des droits linguistiques et
culturels mais dans un canada à 10 pas
question d'un canada de donc d'emblée un
rejet de la théorie des deux nations et
la trudeau affichait vraiment ses
couleurs
la veille de l'élection c'est le 24 juin
fête nationale des québécois rejoindre
c'est la fête des canadiens français il
ne reconnaît pas l'existence de la
nation qu'un des françaises il a pas
d'affaires à s'y présenter
[Musique]
pierre trudeau est aux premières loges
du défilé devant le parc la fontaine
maintenant ici est interrompu par des
manifestants qui protestent contre sa
présence des bouteilles et autres objets
sont lancés sur lui il reste en place
les manifestants sont réprimés sans
pitié par l'escouade antiémeute tout
neuf de la police de montréal le
journaliste claude jean de virieu
rapporte et fiston m'a demandé de vous
dire ce que j'ai vu j'ai vu les
policiers perdent leur contrôle
claude jean de virieu est suspendue par
la direction de radio canada les
journalistes protestent en refusant de
participer à la soirée électorale donc
c'est finalement il n'y a pas de soirée
électorale
si bien que le lendemain marc thibault
dit mais il faut reprendre ce soir
électorale la pile devrait essayer de
notre mieux de faire un espèce de bilan
de l'état de la situation à travers le
pays dont les pays en 3 ou en 4 et puis
on avait chacun notre portion moi je
pense que je vais provinces de
l'atlantique bon wilfried ya des avec le
québec michel serres avec
cette émission a disparu des archives ce
qui nous reste c'est la soirée
électorale au réseau anglais
de triomphe avec 154 sièges sur 264
ce qui s'était passé la veille mais avec
un impact au moins est ce qu elle même
au québec parce qu'il va obtenir une
majorité une majorité des députés au
québec alors on voit que sa bravade sur
l'estrade où pat lafontaine ça a été
payant pierre trudeau remporte 56 sièges
sur 74 au québec plus de 53 % des voix
sa croisade contre les séparatistes
comme il les appelle ne fait que
commencer
elvis est reine de tout ce qui était la
sienne et leur
il a joué aussi au moment du premier
référendum du québec à 80 ya
ramené la concession canada l'année
suivante il était devenu aussi au moment
de l'entente du lac meech
en ces quinze années au pouvoir il
imposera un contrôle des prix des
salaires pour juguler une inflation
galopante il adoptera une politique
énergétique centralisé qui lui vaudra
des ennemis acharnés dans l'ouest
canadien il essaiera de se distancer des
états unis et sera le pionnier de
l'ouverture vers la chine et cuba
surtout on doit à pierre trudeau la loi
sur les langues officielles et une
charte des droits et des libertés dans
une nouvelle constitution mais sans le
québec malgré cela quand il quittera le
pouvoir en 1984 il comptera au québec 74
députés sur 75 et ce qui est assez
exceptionnel c'est que
37 ans après le retrait de pierre
trudeau débit police et se sont fait
juste est il se retrouve premier
ministre cadres écrit dans la
constitution
rapatrié par son père permet qu'on
inscrive que le québec est une nation
nationale sociétés distinctes ce que
mulroney bourassa avait tenté de le
faire reconnaître au reste du cade donc
c'est quand même assez paradoxal est
pour le moins attendu
[Musique]